well meanwhile nearly the entire NYPD is
on alert for Donald Trump's return here
to New York sources tell CBS New York
that 35 thousand officers are on standby
for the arraignment Trump is encouraged
his supporters to protest the indictment
Jeff begaze has more now on how police
are preparing
over the weekend and noticeable but
quiet police president stood outside the
courthouse where Donald Trump will be
arraigned we're pretty comfortable
dealing with large crowds and large
demonstrations Michael Alcazar was a
retired detective who spent more than 30
years with the NYPD he said that there
would likely be several hundred police
officers on the scene Tuesday they're
going to have a detail of uniform police
officers all around the perimeter of the
courthouse and nearby blocks right the
whole Police Department's on standby
just in case we need more police
officers to respond to the scene uh if
in case it gets out of hand in a social
media post the week before his
indictment Mr Trump teased his upcoming
rest and wrote protests take our nation
back you'll never take back our country
with weakness it seemed to Echo the call
he made on January 6 more than two years
ago thank you
and that's something Alcazar told us the
NYPD is likely prepared for you're not
storming the the courthouses that's not
gonna happen I'm sure our Executives
have reviewed January 6 and what went
wrong so they're anticipating any kind
of issues like that
you can call what's happening now
the Calm before the potential storm you
can see this part of New York is is
really sealed off in a lot of ways
around Trump Tower you have all these
barricades you have a lot of police
officers and they're already moving the
media back extending that perimeter
around Trump Tower now the thing is it's
not just the NYPD it's also the FBI and
the Secret Service an army of law
enforcement Vlad
Jeff I do hope that it does stay calm
rather than seeing that storm thank you
very much